Gilbert king discusses Thurgood Marshall's defense of a capital case based on
his Pulitzer Prize winning book devil in the Grove,
Thurgood Marshall,
the Groveland boys and the dawn of a new America.
This particular case started with a 17 year old girl named norm of pageant and
she was,
um,
at the age of 16,
she had already been married and separated from her husband and it was sort of
around town.
The rumors were that Norma was being beaten by her husband and he was,
her husband was sort of a narrow dwell at the time.
And um,
he was about 22 years old and they tried to get back together,
went out to a dance one night,
something happened in the car between them.
And the next thing you know,
she is on the side of a road claiming that she's been raped by four black men.
When word got out,
uh,
the clan rolled into town and all the locals just started burning down the black
community.
This is in Groveland,
Florida,
1949.
So here you see three stellar members of the community,
uh,
prosecutor who is Jesse Hunter on the left.
Sheriff Willis Mccall in the center of the big hat man.
They called him and his deputy James Yates.
And this was the family of a,
one of the alleged rapist.
One of the,
one of the alleged rapist named sort of saw what was happening and he skipped
town and sheriff McCall went up,
got a posse of a thousand men.
They shot him down,
um,
killed him.
Uh,
I think they said something like 400 bullets were in the body.
Unbelievable.
But these are the three Groveland boys.
And uh,
this case is a lot,
a lot like the Scottsboro boys.
It's just not as well known.
And you know,
it's funny,
I went through a lot of readings and Marshall,
this isn't even a case that makes it to Marshall's biographies very often and it
was one of the most dangerous cases he ever got involved in sort of explaining
to that.
But there you see sheriff McCall,
he sort of a notorious sheriff on the left and,
um,
he was every bit as important in enforcing the death penalty.
Then the prosecutor,
uh,
you know,
what happened was Norma Padgett claimed when this first happened,
she couldn't recognize the victims.
She didn't recognize them.
Um,
later on after a talk with prosecutors and,
and,
and a sheriff McCall,
she finally figured out who these men were and she could name every single one
of them naturally.
And they were basically who sheriff McCall considered troublemakers.
Um,
the tall,
the tall kid in the middle 16 year old Charles Greenley was in another jail at
the,
at this point.
And he wasn't even involved with this,
but,
but normal,
they had to have four.
And so they just picked him.
Okay.
Uh,
this was right after the,
right after the alleged rape.
This was the,
um,
one of the editorials in the Orlando Sentinel,
uh,
the supreme penalty,
the Lake County tragedy,
and basically they're already lining up the pot.
The,
the fact that this community is going to put these kids to death.
Um,
this actually w was the,
uh,
played a large role in the supreme court verdict on this,
which I'll read to you in a moment.
Uh,
this is just,
you can see what happened after the writing.
This is really interesting.
After the rioting life magazine,
send a photographer down like the day after while they were still investigating
this.
And so you have sort of this real time photo repertory of this murder case.
This is the spot where the alleged rape was supposed to have taken,
taken place.
Uh,
Norma pageant is standing way in front of the car.
They're a part of the agreement with the photographer was that he wouldn't
photograph her or if he did,
he'd be from a distance.
Um,
here you can see Willie pageant,
that's enormous,
separated husband.
Um,
Jeffrey Hunter's the prosecutor and Mabel Norris Reef is the reporter.
They play a really important part of this case,
which I'll explain to you later and you can sort of see behind the prosecutor.
That's normal.
She's just photographer.
Just hit her back there.
This is one of the most,
I think one of the most fascinating photographs that I've ever come across and
it doesn't look like much.
It's,
it's,
it's sort of just telling you that something's happening in this little cafe,
but this is sort of how the death penalty works and this is how justice works
and it's all right here in this photograph.
This guy has a name by the name of Lawrence Bartowski.
Now he had a little cafe on the side of the road outside of Groveland and he was
the first person to see normal pageant that morning.
And Norma pageant came in and told him a story,
but she didn't tell it right away.
She sat down and had coffee with them,
didn't seem to be hurt at all.
And she,
she said that she told Lawrence that she couldn't find her husband.
She didn't know where he was at.
Some black men had come along and got in a fight with her husband and she wanted
to,
she,
if Lawrence would take him back,
take her back to find her husband
that didn't fit the story of a rape.
She knits.
She said nothing about a rape.
She didn't look upset,
she didn't seem hurt.
And so Lauren's Berghoff,
whose father owned this cafe when they came around to talk to him,
they sort of put it in his head like,
what about that rape?
She showed up,
she said she was raped by four men and he said,
actually that's not at all what she said.
And he told a totally different story.
And so you can see the prosecutor in the foreground,
Jesse Hunter sort of trying to get this story out of Lawrence Lawrenceburg off.
This is a 17 year old kid.
He's about to go off to the army and they're basically saying,
you know,
your father has got a nice place here.
It'd be shamed if he lost his license.
All these things threatening and sort of,
and you can see sheriff McCall and James Yates who's deputy sort of glaring at
him because they're used to getting their way in this town.
These guys are stone cold killers,
which I'll explain to you in a little bit,
but they were absolutely feared in this town and the sheriff was the most
powerful man in town.
More powerful than the prosecutor.
More powerful than anybody.
And they could make things happen.
They made bodies disappear in the orange groves with central Florida.
Uh,
they were killers.
And so you can just see that look on them.
It's just sort of,
that's how you're influencing justice.
Yeah.
Burt off by the way,
refused to go along with them.
Um,
and later on and that he comes back from the army and he stands up to the
prosecutor and like a 45 minute cross examination,
uh,
one of the most heroic testimonies I've ever seen considering,
you know,
that he had family members in the clan are allegedly,
uh,
they threatened to shut his father's business down and he just,
his mother said,
get up there and do what's right,
which is unbelievable in the 1940s,
to be honest with you,
it's Thurgood Marshall.
It,
he just got to see a picture of her.
The first trial,
the growth and boys was a disaster and,
and the Naacp did get involved.
Marshall wasn't doing the criminal case but you sort of steering it from New
York.
Um,
it was reversed on,
went to the Supreme Court and they both got can both men got convicted,
sentenced to the electric chair.
The third boy,
16 year old kid,
he got life in prison.
Um,
but Marshall knew when they were taking this trial that the way they selected
the jury was just,
there was already an opinion.
Castle verse Texas,
I believe it was that had already said that you couldn't select jury members by
hand,
which is what they were doing.
They were saying he's one of the best blacks we have.
He can be on the jury and then they excuse them.
But that's how they were doing it.
There was no other way of selecting them apparently.
So once this case had gone to the Supreme Court,
Marshall took the case.
Um,
they knew where they were going to win.
In fact,
Florida knew they were going to get destroyed.
They set up their attorney general and he's just like,
this is going to be easy for you guys because the supreme court like two months
earlier,
I just ruled on this.
So they knew it was going to happen.
But I want to read to you because this is,
this was the,
um,
justice Jackson wrote the opinion and he's talking about the jury selection.
Any,
anybody,
he,
he reads a very strong opinion into this and I'll just read it to you.
Uh,
the situation presented by this record is not different in essentials from that
which was founded denial of due process in more verse Dempsey under these
circumstances for the court to reverse these convictions upon the sole ground
that the method of jury selection discriminated against the Negro race is to,
is to stress the trivial and ignore the important.
While this record discloses discrimination,
which under normal circumstances might be prejudicial,
this trial took place under conditions and was accompanied by events,
would deny defendants a fair trial before any kind of jury.
I do not see as a practical matter how any Negro on the jury would have dared to
cause a disagreement or acquittal.
The only chances these negroes had of acquittal would have been in the courage
and decency of some sturdy and forthright white person of sufficient standing to
face and live down the odium among his white neighbors.
That's such a vote if required,
would have brought to me the technical question of discrimination and the jury
selection has only theoretical importance.
The case presents one of the best examples of one of the worst menaces to
American justice.
It is on that ground that I would reverse and that was a pretty strong opinion.
And basically they're saying that the sheriff who stood on the steps and said,
I just got those boys to confess,
this will all be taken care of soon.
But there was no confessions brought into evidence.
They would.
There was,
they knew that will get reversed even they were smart enough to know that then,
but yet the word was out there that these three guys had confessed.
It was all over the newspapers.
The coverage was awful.
And that's what,
that's what Justice Jackson was talking about when you,
when you said,
you know,
it's one of the best examples of one of the worst medicines to American justice.
One man who didn't particularly care for the Supreme Court,
uh,
decision was I'm Sheriff Willis.
Mccall Mccall said it was a decision that was influenced by subversives up in
New York,
um,
bunch of Naacp lawyers who've gotten to the heads of the Supreme Court justices
and he didn't really care much for the opinion,
but by law he was required to go pick up the prisoners and bring them back for a
second trial.
And what do you know they tried to escape?
This is,
um,
McCall actually put these guys in the car,
cuffed him together and took them down a dirt road on the way back to the,
to the jail for the trial on the eve of the trial,
um,
Samuel Sheppard,
who is the one in the Supreme Court Opinion Shepherd versus a Florida is on the
left.
He is,
um,
he was killed instantly.
This is also another remarkable photograph for what it represents.
This was taken about 10 minutes after the shooting.
So after the shooting,
McCall got on with his deputy and said,
get the police back here.
They tried to escape.
Uh,
the police showed up with a photographer.
There was a town hall meeting and they came and took this photograph,
the Flash Flyer fired as soon as the flash fired,
uh,
the prosecutor who happened to be there as well,
said one of those guys just moved.
So Walter urban on the right was actually still alive.
So Marshall had come down that who came down for the trial,
he was going to conduct this trial himself.
Um,
you can feed in here with the young Paul Perkins who was,
um,
this was one of his first cases out of college.
He,
he,
this is the first case he ever was paid cash.
You got three 75,
an hour to two to practice law.
Before that he was being paid in ham and oranges.
So he was very excited to be working with Thurgood Marshall.
Needless to say,
Marshall came down and now he gets a chance to go into the hospital and meet
Walter Urban.
It hasn't met Walter urban yet.
And Walter urban tells a very different story about the escape.
Uh,
urban tells a story that they,
they just went down a dirt road and McCall just said,
get out of the car.
And as soon as they started to get out of the car,
he shot them.
Uh,
now he's cuffed to Samuel Shepard.
Shepard falls really can't go anywhere.
I can't run anywhere.
You stuck.
He takes two bullets,
one in the side,
one in the chest.
And um,
there's a third bullet wounds that,
that they've accounted for all the bullets.
But there's one bullet they haven't accounted for.
And that was the neck wound.
And this is where urban story gets a little bit intense.
And Marshall's hearing this,
the reporters are hearing this for the first time.
He said that
he was lying on the side of the road and McCall made that phone call to get his
deputy back here and the deputy drove back to the scene,
took out his flashlight and he's shining the down and he says,
this one's not dead.
He pulls his gun and fires it straight down at urban,
hits him in the neck,
goes right through his neck.
Okay,
so now you have two versions of what happened in this story.
You have McCall's version that there was an escape that these two guys were
coming at them and McCall was backing up and firing his weapon.
Six bullets,
five of them that were,
were accounted for because they were in the bodies of the victims.
The sixth bullet was unaccounted for.
So if you believe McCall's story,
that bullet would never be seen because he got shot in the neck,
uh,
while he was being attacked.
But urban says that the deputy came back,
shot him straight to the neck.
So the FBI hears this,
they go back to the scene,
they find the blood spot,
they start digging in 10 inches under,
they find the bullet.
So it is urban story.
After all,
remarkably,
the FBI sat on this evidence and didn't it never released it.
It just kind of died in the files,
uh,
along with the bullet information.
Very strange that this would happen.
But these are the things that happen when you have a of state attorney who's a
known segregationist.
Uh,
they just managed to cover this up.
In fact,
the,
um,
the reason McCall was not indicted after evidence like this was that the judge
in the case,
the criminal case said that,
you know,
let's just go by the coroner's report.
The coroner's report was very accurate as to what happened.
The coroner's report was made up of six of Willis.
Mccall has friends who said it was self defense.
And so when the call was never charged on this,
um,
there's James Yates,
the deputy who's the one who fired the bullet
the second,
the second trial did go forward.
Um,
and it was pretty much even,
even with Thurgood Marshall represented,
it was just no way that they were going to win.
And they knew that they,
they,
it was 12 white jurors.
They knew what they were up against and,
and they were just not going to do it.
One of the things that they were up against was falsified evidence.
This is James Yates,
the killer.
Um,
yeah.
You can see the newspaper articles that were running at Scotland Yard.
Please don't take our gate.
This was a Yates was in charge of putting the evidence together for this case.
And what he did was he found these,
he was supposedly this forensic genius.
He was able to make footprints of plaster in Paris,
in the sand that put Walter urban at the scene of the crime alleged crime.
What do you really did?
Was he confiscated Urban's shoes and went home and made footprints and brought
them in for evidence.
Um,
Marshall actually hired a very sophisticated,
um,
forensic expert who worked for the FBI.
You did the Lindbergh kid.
I mean,
he was very adamant that these footprints were false.
That there would've been a different way of convex impressions.
And he said these were false and,
but the jury,
all the prosecution really had to do was say,
who are you going to believe these negroes up here?
Or are you going to believe are find deputies?
And this was exactly how it played out.
So they got their verdict.
They got their death sentence.
At the time,
actually Florida was getting such bad publicity for this case that the governor
actually stepped in and offered a plea to Walter urban said,
we can end this now.
Just take life in prison,
will stop going through the death penalty.
Just confessed.
Just say you did it.
That's all you have to do.
And Marshall's strategy was to sort of,
he was hoping that that urban would take the plea.
He really knew that Florida meant business and they were gonna kill him.
And that he really encouraged him.
But Walter Urban said,
well,
what do I have to do to do this?
And Marshall explained to him,
you said you have to go before the judge and said and say that you raped Nora
pageant.
And he said,
well,
you can say it for me.
I'm not saying I didn't rape her and he wouldn't say it.
And this was to save his life.
Basically Marshall was trying to persuade them,
say,
we can get this taken care of later.
Just save your life.
Because there's ways we can influence the political process and,
and take care of this.
And he was encouraging.
But,
but urban would not lie and his mother wouldn't lie on the stand.
His mother could have saved his life to by by saying that that Walter was home.
But the family just would not lie and they wouldn't say,
he would not admit to raping.
Okay.
All right.
It's pretty interesting.
And here you see Jack Greenberg,
I don't know if you send me to know him.
He was head of the Naacp or the legal defense on for awhile.
And this was one of his first cases.
Greenberg was interesting because he had stormed the beaches of Ua Jima
and
how I asked him what were you scared?
And he goes,
not as scared as I was in Groveland because when he,
the night before trial,
the was circling around his hotel and he was putting like dressers in front of
the doors.
I mean he was absolutely scared out of his mind.
The second trial was interesting because Marshall,
here's the DNA died,
the dynamic at play here you haven't an African American lawyer and she,
he is supposedly questioning a white victim of rape.
And there were all sorts of things that Marshall would not do.
And one of them was,
he was not going to stand before a jury of 12 white rural men and questioning
the integrity of this woman's character.
It was called the,
uh,
flower,
a white southerners flower of white southern womanhood that would be considered
so untestable and that an automatic conviction.
So they,
they,
they were very careful about that.
So the only way they could really only defense they could mount was one of
mistaken identity because that didn't impugn her reputation.
And they're saying,
oh,
we're not saying the rape didn't happen,
we're just saying,
you got,
you selected the wrong people.
And it was very,
she was very adamant about who,
you know,
recognizing these men.
Now actually when I went through the FBI files,
the FBI files were sealed for 60 years.
Um,
so I just got them released a couple of years ago and I went through them.
And they are fascinating because they include a lot of off the record comments.
And so you had the police chief,
you know,
telling the FBI,
giving the statement,
and then pulling the FBI guy to the side and saying,
I'll tell you what really happened here.
And so those things are in the record.
It's pretty fascinating.
But Norma Padgett,
when she was doing her FBI statement,
she,
it was completely different than what she said on the stand,
but of course this never came out in the trial.
So she contradicted herself.
You could say she committed perjury and one of those statements or the other.
Um,
but that's how,
that's how Hamstrung Marshall was in this defense.
Now,
what's really interesting,
I showed you earlier the picture of Jesse Hunter,
the prosecutor and Mabel Norris Reese,
who was the white reporter after the shooting.
When McCall shot these two guys,
they started to have a change of heart.
Now they,
this is the only time I'd seen this,
the prosecutor,
the prosecutor started to leak material and information to the NAACP.
So what they were basically doing,
they,
he would not go,
he was going to go ahead and he was going to prosecute for the death penalty.
But beside behind the scenes,
the prosecutor was leaking material that would be helpful to the defense.
Um,
which was,
uh,
I had,
I had not come across that before.
And in fact the sheriff McCall was so upset by this that he leaked himself
through one of his,
he was friends with the assistant prosecutor.
He leaked to the Naacp that the prosecutor was in on the murder with him.
And so this showed up in Marshall's office and Marshall just dismissed it out of
hand.
He figured it out.
He said,
McCall is trying to drag the prosecutor down cause he knew the prosecutor was
leaking this.
So after,
after Jesse Hunter wins this conviction and gets Walter Urban Center the death
penalty,
the electric chair,
what he does is he,
he writes the governor and says,
we got it all wrong.
And he says,
I really don't think,
I think you should find a way to stop this right now.
And that this infuriated McCall because McCall was the one who really ran this
county.
And so for,
for McCall started accusing them of suddenly falling into the communist hands
becoming senile.
And one of the things that's interesting and this is the will to win.
Like he wouldn't,
the prosecutor,
Jesse Hunter would not stop the case.
He had to win it.
And to the extent that he went to,
to win this was kind of remarkable.
I think you'll find it pretty interesting.
He,
um,
in his closing argument,
he stands before the,
at this point,
Marshall and his assistants are just making,
you know,
one list,
one long list of prosecutorial misconduct.
Uh,
at the very end of his is a closing argument.
Jesse Hunter stands up,
walks over to the rail and starts talking to the 12 men on the jury and he says,
gentlemen,
you,
uh,
you know,
I haven't told anybody about this,
but I have a terminal disease and this is probably going to be my last case.
And I show we'd like to go out with a win.
And you know,
I wouldn't lie to you,
so if you wouldn't mind,
just let me go out as a,
as a winner.
And Marshall didn't even object at this point.
They're just making a list of all these things.
Um,
so those are the kinds of things that they were up against.
Another thing that was interesting,
it was Jesse Hunter in the second trial when they brought the forensic expert
up,
hunter was just walking up and down the isles making fun of the witness.
And the judge wouldn't even stop him.
So he would say,
why to fancy man with your fancy explanations.
And he was yelling this stuff and at one point you can see in the transcript,
can you get him to stop your honor,
proceed.
And it was just going on and on like this.
And so the case was,
the second trial was kind of a,
a carnival in a,
in a lot of different ways.
But um,
so yeah,
that was
urban did testify,
but you know,
it was one of those things where he didn't know what happened.
He,
he,
and,
and that Marshall made a point of that saying,
you know,
this is not the behavior of someone.
Technically it was one of his neighbors.
They lived near each other in Groveland,
Norma pageant and Walter Urban.
And what,
what's strange is that urban gets up on the stand it and he,
he basically says,
I saw them on the side of the road.
We help them fix the car and then we drove away,
which was true.
Um,
and they,
they went back to bed and woke up the next morning to go to work when the police
shut up.
And Marshall tried to make the point.
He goes,
in all my years I've never seen a black man who rapes a neighbor and goes to
work.
Like nothing happened.
When they left her alive,
it made no sense to him.
And so that's how he knew that he knew that urban was innocent,
but he really knew when urban refused to say that he ray,
he could have saved his life and he refused to just say I raped her.
One of the most fascinating parts of the story to me is,
is Marshall actually hired a spy to go down to Florida.
The young girl who was just anti capital punishment and she went down south and
she had this world is a world peace pin that she wore around and she went around
to all these different people in this clan community and said,
I want you to sign my petition against capital punishment.
And she went down and she got all these people to sign in Bay County and one of
the things she did,
which was fascinating,
she got Norma pageant to sign that petition and c they were country Baptist and
they didn't really have a strong opinion.
They,
they had a strong opinion about guilt or innocence,
but they weren't really in favor of capital punishment.
And so by this spy who I never was able to find her,
she had a fake name and Marshall just hired her from a detective agency.
She went down there and got my call,
tried to get my call to sign it and call,
get outta here,
shoot her away.
But she did get the pageants to sign that.
And so it's sort of this activism in a way.
She was a detective and a spy,
but she was also an activist.
She really strongly believed she was very anti capital punishment and by her
going around,
she lived,
she went fishing with Norma paget.
She's,
she went under the guise of wanting to buy real estate and in Groveland and so
they were very friendly even in this little clan community and they were against
capital punishment.
And so that was one of the factors that made the Governor Leroy Collins
actually,
pardon Walter Irvin.
It was,
you know,
a lot of different factors.
But one of them was seeing that the victim in this case,
it was willing to sign that.
I will add that it doesn't end quite that happily because sheriff McCall found
out about that petition and mounted this big campaign to press charges because
there was a communist loosen our neighborhood and she was getting to sign
capitol punishment and they were under a ruse.
And then he tried to get normal pageant to recant it and say that was not my
signature.
He tried everything,
but he was unsuccessful.
So Walter urban was,
life was spared.
Walter Irvin had had a pretty strange,
um,
he served 19 years in jail and he got,
he got out,
um,
I think it was 1968 and within a year he decided he wanted to go back to lake
county because it was forbidden.
But he,
uh,
one of his uncles had passed away,
so we wanted to go back for the funeral.
And so he had to alert Lee county that he was coming to lake county for funeral.
He got to Lake County and they found him dead in a car.
So Mabel Norris Reese was a big part of this story.
She just immediately says,
McCall got to him like 20 years later and McCall God to him,
uh,
nothing was ever,
you know,
the,
the corner just sort of hung up and said it was natural causes.
Marshall never believed that.
And in fact,
Marsha was sitting as a justice of the supreme court when he got news of this.
He still called Hoover and said,
I want an investigation.
And McCall McCall was like a nemesis effort of his for many years and he never
forgot that.
So that was Walter Urban's fate.
Yup.
Yeah.